make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up
and uh make sure you guys hit the like
button if you enjoy the video and yeah
let's begin
all right what's going on guys this is
rob and we are back again with dc future
state and the dark detective and again i
love this this story it's really really
good it's probably my favorite thing
coming out of
out of dc future state batman's the best
thing coming out of dc future state
it really is right dark detective is the
best thing coming out of this it's a
really really really
cool story so for those of you guys who
are just now joining us
one i invite you guys to check out our
batman playlist down in the description
where we have
everything related to batman going all
the way back to scott snyder's new 52
batman run
right so that whole playlist will
basically get you current on everything
regarding the character
but also with dc's future state this
takes place in the future
and and this part of the story that
we're covering right now is actually the
first time that we get any real measure
of a time frame
as far as when this happens and and so
on and so forth but in effect
batman or bruce wayne was essentially
killed or at least believed to have been
killed and batman was more or less out
of commission now as we go over this
it'll become a little more apparent in
terms of what's going on because even
the first issue
left a lot of mystery going on but what
you end up getting here
is that with bruce wayne basically
redoning his batman suit albeit a kind
of makeshift version
there's a few guys who are hanging out
at this port by the the authority
shipyard
and just plan on robbing it up the
barrels right now when they're when
they're in the middle of doing this
they're basically met by the arrival of
these things called cybers which are
basically the machine versions of the
magistrates
police forces more or less right the
guys who kind of enforce law and order
depending on the situation
sometimes the magistrate itself will get
involved but more often than not it's
usually just the cybers that kind of go
out and maintain order just because of
the fact that when their machines
won because they're insanely durable and
two because they're not people you don't
really have to worry about a loss of
life
and so of course batman ends up fitting
off against this cyber here but in the
process we also jump back
a little bit where we jump back to the
moment when he was essentially shot and
attacked
by this peacekeeper now he's referred to
as peacekeeper number one which really
seems to be the top dog the person who
runs the entire army of all these cybers
and the forces of the magistrate and the
big question that bruce wayne finds
himself
asking here that even he doesn't seem to
fully know the answer to is
why did they kill him right why did they
go directly after him uh how is it that
the peacekeeper knew that taking out
bruce wayne was taking out batman now
obviously us is the reader we know and
presumably bruce wayne knows on some
level that the peacekeepers figured out
that his identity was batman right now
the question is how did they learn that
because it's one of those things
where bruce wayne keeps his identity
under lock and key nobody
except those that he wants to know are
aware of the fact that he's actually
batman and so if they managed to find a
way or figure out who he was then the
question is how right how could they
have possibly done that we'll actually
get the answer to that question
in this particular story but what ends
up happening is that in the moment when
he's shot he basically ends up falling
down into the water only to basically
see the body of what he calls a john doe
right we're not really given a name for
this person
and this person doesn't really matter in
you know outside of the fact that the
body kind of rises to the surface
and it allows bruce wayne the
opportunity to trick the peacemaker into
thinking that this is actually bruce
wayne's body that and the fact that he
had thrown an electro grenade which was
able to throw the peacekeeper off is
just kind of like okay cool so it looks
like batman's basically dead the
peacekeeper is temporarily incapacitated
now
one of the things that bruce wayne kind
of muses about here is that once he
managed to escape
that you would think that he would give
him a time for reflection and he said
nope that's not the case at all as soon
as he was out he immediately had to find
a way to stop the bleeding and then
start going down the path of figuring
out who it was that did this to him and
why and so what we end up finding out
is that in the aftermath of all this
with him kind of operating as a
vigilante kind of switching back to to
the events
of what are happening right now that
what he's doing here is he's actually
taking up residence with a guy by the
name of noah and that he essentially
offered his name as
jeff right that's really all all it is i
mean he's kind of the the first and last
name that he really gives here
is jeff marks so we know of course he's
operating on a fake identity to be
honest i'm a little disappointed that he
didn't use the name matches malone right
that's kind of bruce wayne's alter ego
whenever he goes underground and starts
operating within the criminal community
to kind of figure out what's going on
and put his ear to the ground and then
find a way to subvert their actions
things like that so i'm a little
disappointed in that
but noah is one of these guys where he
kind of borderlines on schizophrenia
right he is a false
like a full-on conspiracy theorist but
not all conspiracy theorists are
schizophrenics i imagine all
schizophrenics or conspiracy theorists i
don't know that's really true or not but
the idea here is that he's one of these
guys where he basically seems to have a
difficult time
differentiating between reality and
fantasy that he's very much caught up in
the idea that like aliens are out there
and they're trying to like they're
basically you know
poisoning the water to use mind control
on humans like the kind of nonsensical
conspiracy theories that you hear all
the time right you know they're trying
to control human beings and so on and so
forth but the the place that bruce wayne
stays
is essentially the bunker right it's
essentially the basement of noah is
really all it is but his big mission
here is to figure out what's going on
right and what he basically says is to
track the money and the reason why
is because there's three companies that
really seem to operate
around the same time that have basically
made it possible for mayor nikano of
gotham to hire in
these these anti-vigilante you know this
anti-vigilante force called the
magistrate and then create you know give
them all the tools and weapons they need
to achieve their goal and these three
companies are neocorp draft tech and
plexi tech
now carl bennington is introduced us by
way of bruce wayne
as kind of being this guy who's been
around for a long long time
but in terms of dc's publication history
this is the first time we're seeing him
and the little bit of history that we do
get about his character
is basically this idea that he was an
inept businessman that he was
effectively running his company because
he's really his family's company into
the ground but by some manner he's now
become the head of plexitech he's now
that company's ceo and we're not really
told exactly how these dots get
connected presumably it's one of these
things where it's just a great big huge
conspiracy that's going on but we don't
necessarily know
for sure but the real time frame of the
first real time frame that we get is
that these corporations
didn't exist before the events of the
joker war but now they do exist and so
of course this is the first time that we
actually have dc future state
tying to the events of what's recently
been written in the batman comics so we
know it takes place probably a few years
after that but the idea of gotham
becoming so advanced so fast and growing
at the pace that it is so fast
does kind of stretch the limits of
credulity but it could also be one of
these things where if a colossal amount
of money just started dumping into
gotham city and it was all for the
purpose of just reinvigorating or
revitalizing the entire city itself then
it could happen depending on
how much money and all the resources
that are there but again we don't really
have all these dots connected we don't
really know how we got from the end of
joker
war to this particular situation here of
course as the story unfolds
we'll learn more about it but one of the
things that goes on is that batman's
really here for the purpose of just
uh reconnaissance right he's actually
looking to achieve a particular goal
and the reason why is because once he
gets into this location what he ends up
finding is that he's
immediately set upon by all by these
little motion sensors and so on which
he's able to dodge
but it also leads to to a kind of ruse
in the sense that this was basically not
really a trap
but a type of security that was set up
to where you had the main security front
which was you know like motion sensors
things like that then you had backup
sensors right you had backups for
backups and so it's one of these things
where the magistrate could always focus
on the idea of maintaining redundancies
but the whole point of batman being here
is to steal
one of these little tiny drones that
they have like a little micro drone and
what he tells us this is what's kind of
interesting here what did he what he
tells us
is that this is one of these situations
where it was developed by wayne
enterprises
somewhere along the line the wayne
enterprise is going to use it for
a kind of surveillance system right to
map the tunnels and things like that
within gotham the little nooks and
crannies not really for the purpose of
spying on people
but to try to keep gotham or try to
figure out what all is going on below
gotham city now we can largely chalk a
lot
of this up to like the court of owl
story from scott snyder that in the
aftermath of that and bruce wayne coming
to the realization that the court of
owls was operating within gotham city
for
you know hundreds of years and batman
never knew it probably raises the
question
what else doesn't he know about the city
of gotham and so having a kind of
surveillance system that's not really
designed to spy on people but to give
them a much better view of what's going
on in the city of gotham
seems to make logical sense the problem
is that while he's analyzing this thing
and while he's studying this thing he
also begins to realize that it has
cloaking tech right which means that
it's probably being used within the city
of gotham and nobody really seems to
know exactly what's going on now of
course his entire study of all this is
immediately cut to a halt when you have
noah who comes
running up on the door that bruce wayne
locks with a baseball bat ranting about
how they've all found them right about
how like they've been found out they've
been discovered and like they're here
right presumably the magistrates and and
their forces
now in response to this we don't really
have an instance where like you know
bruce wayne and noah end up getting into
a fight instead what they do
is they basically put up this kind of
sensor right this sort of siren
this designed to detect uh you know
signals that aren't supposed to be there
and then create a kind of alarm
alarming sound ever since you know every
you know every time that happens
the problem is that as soon as it's
there it immediately starts going off
right it immediately
immediately starts buzzing and for noah
in his his
schizophrenia or mental illness or what
have you he just kind of lets it ride
right because it basically reminds him
constantly that there are forces out
there constantly trying to spy on him
for bruce wayne he kind of seems to run
with it as well and he's the one that
sort of helps him set it up but getting
back into his thing and sort of
analyzing what's going on
we end up finding out that carl
bennington has actually been killed
right he's basically been assassinated
and so the question
at that point it kind of turns into a
murder mystery how was this done right
and so using the goggles of noah that
just kind of exists as regular goggles
along with tech that he got from the
from the cyber as well as this little
mini drone he's allowed to basically
he's able to basically hack into their
frequency and when he does that he kind
of starts looking around and seeing
what's going on in gotham only to
discover that gotham itself
seems to have these even these little
small nano drones that are completely
new that are flying around the city
itself and so once he attains one of
those
then it turns into breaking that one
down and figuring out what's going on
with this little drunk and when that
when he finally figures that out he
starts going from different version a
different version because they
had these kind of beefed up security
measures the first drone he had was just
kind of a small little drone that he
found out there these are more advanced
and operate in a much larger number and
so it looks like what the magistrate had
done
had basically taken the technology
developed originally by wayne industries
capitalized on it seemingly improved on
it and then in turn
dispersed them throughout the city and
that's exactly what turns out to be the
case that once he finally manages to
access one of these drones once he
manages to break into his technology to
effectively hack it then he starts
learning that all these different drones
are flying around the city of gotham now
one thing that does happen
is that when he ends up having like one
of these little surveillance devices
kind of one of the bigger ones that
manages to track him down he of course
destroys it runs away and then
runs into uh runs into the newer batman
coming out of batman
future state right so he runs into that
guy it's only a small little thing they
don't actually fight each other which
would be kind of cool if they did
there's almost kind of an understanding
between these two right and
of course neither one seems to know the
other's identity but there's kind of an
understanding where it's like okay
you know you're the you're you're batman
like you're the you're the old batman
the way that it used to be
uh i'm batman the way he is now right so
they kind of acknowledge that neither
one's really operating within the
confines of the law
but they're both working in their own
way to take down the magistrate and try
to end their control over gotham right
and so because of that they just end up
sort of leaving
the other thing that sort of indicates
here is that they may have met before
now we're not really given any
indication like yes i ran into him
multiple times before but you know again
it's one of these things where it's kind
of you stay away i stay away they don't
really get into blows it's not like this
you know future state batman shows up
and says hey
like stop what you're doing or i'm going
to take you in right because they're
both essentially operating
illegally and so following that little
encounter that you end up picking back
up with bruce wayne and as bruce wayne
is going through
all these little this this little drone
and analyzing its abilities and so on
and so forth when he hacks into the
drone itself he realizes that they're
all part of a singular network and that
because they're all part of a singular
network that they are reporting back to
a singular server or a series of servers
but these little things being as small
as they are and having cloaking
abilities they're basically
everywhere in the city of gotham they're
in people's homes they're in people's
bathrooms like they're they're
everywhere they see everything that's
going on
across gotham 24 hours a day seven days
a week and so if that's the case because
it's supposed to be inaccessible
then bruce wayne rationalizes that there
would probably be a few instances
when they're a little sloppy or they
just kind of operate based on the idea
that yeah these little drones are there
but no one's gonna see what's happening
anyway
and so using the using their his ability
to access the servers he looks up the
murder of carl bennington only to find
out that carl bennington was killed by
the peacemakers and so when bruce wayne
looks at that and says that he was
he was essentially you know an attempted
assassination by peacemaker number one
on him
that carl bennington has been killed by
the peacemaker then he starts to put two
and two together and he comes to this
realization
that when the peacemakers first started
seizing power in gotham that they wanted
all the technology of wayne enterprises
that they had to use for their own ends
but wayne enterprises
said no they shot them down and the
reason why is because he didn't want
anybody to to use that technology for
for his own ends you know use it for
nefarious purposes that the surveillance
technology was not supposed to be used
to kind of usher in
a kind of totalitarian state or
totalitarian city where whoever's
controlling them has total control and
authority and they spy on everybody and
all that kind of stuff it was supposed
to be used more for research purposes to
better understand the city of gotham and
so because
because that technology along with other
forms of technology were shot down in
terms of the peacemakers and the
magistrate trying to get their hands on
them that they basically seem to
assassinate bruce wayne they kill him
they take over his company but carl
bennington looks like he was getting in
the business
of selling all this information and this
technology to other people out there and
they killed him to keep that from
happening it's all being done for the
purpose of just tightening their grip
over the course of the city so they can
make themselves an absolute ruler now we
don't really know if the mayor has a
hand in this
or if it's a situation where peacemaker
one is just doing it on his own
taking the opportunity to make himself a
dictator over the city because we don't
know anything about peacemaker number
one we don't really know what's going on
with him and so the result of this is
that once bruce starts to look around
and he starts to use this use these
goggles to start you know monitoring
where all these things are
that's when he realizes noah is not
really crazy that noah putting this
device on the roof is constantly blaring
this this signal that ultimately uh his
daughter ended up taking down it was the
worst thing she could have done
because this signal was keeping all the
drones away but now that that signal is
gone
all these drones are descending on that
house they're all aware that bruce wayne
is there they all know that bruce wayne
is alive the magistrate is completely
it's you know the magistrate and
peacemaker numbers number one they're
all aware that bruce wayne is there
they're trying to find him they're
trying to catch him and presumably they
will right and so as a result of this he
ends up smashing all that technology
everything he's done
he smashed it all to pieces and most
likely he's gonna go even further
underground
before any of these drones can find him
locate him and try to kill him so with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end if you are new here
to comics explain make sure you guys hit
the sub button to become part of the rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video
make sure you drop a like and i will
catch you all later
peace
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
you